وينضم الان الينا من لندن ويليامز
المستشار السابق لدى حلف الشمال الاطلسي
اهلا وسهلا بك سيد ويليامز اذا كل عبارات
الدعم التي سمعت في هذه القمه هل هي كافيه
لطمس الخلاف بشان الدعم او بشان انضمام
اوكرانيا الى النيتو وهذه الخلافات التي
كانت قد شهدتها قمه بوخرست في الماضي في
2008 وهي بعد 15 عاما هل فعلا يمكن القول
انها اختفت
في الحقيقه اعتقد ان توافق الاراء الان
وهو لم يكن عليه الحال قبل هذه القمه اذا
هناك توافق في الاراء انه من المحتم ان
اوكرانيا في مرحله معينه سوف تنضم الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي ولكن يبقى السؤال متى هذه هي
المشكله طبعا الرئيس زيلينسكي عبر عن خيبه
امله بالنسبه الى غياب الجدول الزمني
للانضمامي اوكرانيا للتحالف ولكن حلف شمال
الاطلسي اوضح في صياغه بيانه بشكل
الدبلوماسي ان مستقبل اوكرانيا هو مع حلف
شمال الاطلسي
ويتوقع ان اوكرانيا سوف
يسبح دوله عضو في حلف شمال الاطلسي طبعا
النص لم يشهر الى جدول زمني ولكننا نتحدث
عن نقطه اساسيه ما من دوله في التحالف
تعارض انضمام اوكرانيا الى النيتو يعني
الشروط التي تم الحديث عنها هو على الاقل
الامريكيه هو تحديث اصلاح التحديث الجيش
او تصليح الجيش اجراء اصلاحات في الجيش
واصلاحات في النظام السياسي بحيث يصبح
اكثر
ديمقراطيه وانتهاء الحرب هذه شروط ثلاثه
قالها وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه هل هذه هي
الشروط فقط التي تمنع انضمام اوكرانيا
يعني اذا حدثت اوكرانيا جيشا واذا اجرت
اصلاحات ديمقراطيه وانتهت الحرب عند هذا
الحال يصبح اوكرانيا طريقها ممهده
هذه
الشروط هي واسعه عريضه يمكن ان يتم
استيفاء هذه الشروط بشكل سريع وسهل من قبل
اوكرانيا بالنسبه الى مثال مقدونيا كان
هناك
فتره انتظار
للانضمام الى النيتو لتسعه عشره سنه بحسب
الشروط الخاصه بحلف شمال الاطلسي وهو ما
لم يطبق على اوكرانيا ولم يفرض على
اوكرانيا ولكن طبعا اوكرانيا فيها فساد
وهو امر معروف
والحلفاء والدول الاعضاء في حلف شمال
الاطلسي تود ان ترى تقدما في اوكرانيا على
هذا الصعيد
تقدم يجب ان يحصل ولو كان بطيئا لا يمكننا
ان نتحدث عن وضع حد كامل
للفساد ولكن هذا من بين الشروط اذا ما
ارادت اوكرانيا للانضمام
ولكن واضح ان اوكرانيا منزعجه متمثله في
تصريحات
زينسكي ما الرساله التي خرجت من هذه القمه
بلا شك المجتمعون ارادوا ان يوصلوا رساله
مختلفه تماما عما اوصلها في عام 2008
عندما فتح الباب على انضمام جورجيا
واوكرانيا حينها
اعتقد ان هذه
اللغه او هذه الصيغه
ساعدت بالنسبه الى
اوكرانيا سوف تنضم في نهايه المطاف الى
حلف شمال الاطلسي بالرغم مما قاله السيد
زينينسكي في العام
2008 كان هناك حجج تم التقدم بها بالنسبه
الى
الانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي الفتره
الزمنيه كانت مطروحه ولكن ايضا توافق
الاراء الذي نراه اليوم لم يكن دائما ما
هو الحل عليه كما سبق واستلفت اليوم كل
الدول الاعضاء ترى ان اوكرانيا وفي
النهايه سوف تكون دوله عضو في خلف شمال
الاطلسي ايضا بالنسبه الى المقلب الاخر
يجب النظر في الموقف الروسي ماذا سوف يكون
الموقف الروسي بالنسبه الى انضمام
اوكرانيا الى التحالف يجب دراسه الموقف
الروسي في هذا السياق نعم
اوكرانيا عبرت من ضمن دراسه الموقف الروسي
يعني حينما فتح الباب لاوكرانيا للتقدم
بطلب العضويه او في قمه بوخارست عام 2008
لم تكن روسيا تحتل اي شبر من ارض اوكرانيا
الان وهنالك نزاع حدودي هنالك القرم هنالك
الاقاليم التي استولت عليها القوات
الروسيه
ماذا يعني هل يمكن باي حال من الاحوال في
اي سيناريو ان تنضم اوكرانيا الى النيتو
وهذا النزاع الحدودي موجود وهذه القوات
الروسيه على اراضي يعتبرها نيتو اوكرانيه
في الحقيقه في العام
2008 اجتاحت روسيا واحتلت اجزاء من جورجيا
عندما عدنا الى ذلك التاريخ والحلفاء
عشان ارادوا ان يواجهوا هذا الموضوع
وبالتالي هناك تاريخ طويل من المحاولات في
التوسعيه
للاتحاد الروسي وهو اعتدنا عليه لذلك
يمكننا ان نقول ان الرساله الاخرى اليوم
هي ان حلف شمال الاطلسي سوف يعزز القدرات
العسكريه الدفاعيه بشكل كبير من اجل حمايه
كل شبر من اراضي الدول التابعه
لدى حلف الشمال الاطلسي ضيفنا من لندن